[Music]
so a lot's gonna change when we start
building houses with robots
as you can see with this house zero here
it's not just gonna be sort of a carbon
copy
[Music]
icon is a construction technologies
company presently mostly using
construction-scale 3d printers to attack
the global housing crisis to find ways
to build houses more quickly more
affordably with more design freedom that
are then more resilient more energy
efficient more comfortable we want
better houses and we want more of them
all over the world
building with 3d printers expands design
freedom much more easily than with
conventional construction actually when
you're building the way that we build
with a 3d printer you can dramatically
reduce construction waste with a 3d
printer you print what you need to the
drop and then you stop and that's cool
not just because it rhymes that's cool
because if you've ever been to a
construction site there's often like
more waste than house but we can really
control the amount of waste we're
producing the construction process
[Music]
so south by southwest is very important
to our company we're a local austin
company and once a year the whole world
comes to austin we unveiled the first
permitted 3d printed house in the world
at south by southwest in 2018 and then
this year of course we're unveiling
house zero which is not just inventing
new robotics and software and advanced
materials this is inventing new
architecture architecture specifically
designed to be delivered with a 3d
printer
this house right here house here is
definitely made to be a show house we
sort of pulled out all the stops but
actually for our company most of our
work today and most of the work that
we'll be doing going forward is related
to social housing and affordable housing
and mainstream housing these are the the
areas of real problem uh with regard to
the global housing crisis and so we'll
continue to do this and use these kinds
of exploratory houses but housing
affordability homelessness these are
like the core reasons that our company
exists the real point to be made here is
that at any price point at any finish
level
robotic construction is a new and
exciting paradigm that gives you
opportunities and advantages that you
wouldn't have in any other way
one of the coolest opportunities opened
up by robotic construction is the
opportunity to build on other worlds so
we are engaged with nasa presently to
develop the first off-world construction
system that will allow us to build on
the moon and ultimately mars this is
you know it's very romantic to think
about building humanity's first home on
another world but it's also the deep end
of the pool when it comes to maturing
the technology and making the technology
truly space-age and world-class it's one
of those deals that it just might turn
out that the answers to some of our
problems and questions here on earth are
going to be found
on the moon
in the future i think everyone is going
to want a 3d printed house that's going
to want a house built by robots with
conventional building methods we usually
have to choose between it can either be
beautiful or sustainable or affordable
or fast or
what have you the promise of 3d printing
is that all the things that matter to us
as humans we don't have to choose
between them and i think the opportunity
to have all the things that we want out
of our buildings is their great promise
of 3d printing and why i think this is
going to be the revolution that we've
been looking for
[Music]